it seems like it's very difficult to do
that for the influenza virus
so it's really easy to make an
old-school vaccine
so the the way
the first influenza vaccines were made
because actually jonas salk worked on
them in the 40s you just grow lots of
virus
and you grow it in eggs by the way
chicken eggs
nice
literally wait wait yeah chicken
embryonated so they get fertilized and
there's a 10 or 12 day embryo in it and
you put virus in it it grows up and then
you harvest it you get about 10 mls of
fluid
and then you take that you treat it with
formaldehyde or formalin and it
inactivates the virus so it's no longer
infectious and you just inject that into
people and that was the first flu
vaccine it was made for the the us army
actually and then it got moved over to
people we still use that old school tech
today
so you're taking
can you help me out here okay so this is
a good time to talk about vaccines
okay so you're talking about
you're taking the actual virus right you
put it in an egg you let it grow up
it's very funny that you put in an egg
it's very um it's very poetic
and then uh how do you make it not
um
infection
not effective or whatever not infectious
not infectious is that the right term
here yeah so how do you make it not
infectious you can
treat it with any number of chemicals
that'll
disrupt the particles so it no longer
so that that step of disrupting the
particle
is that very specific to any a
particular variant particle no the same
collection of chemicals you can use for
all kinds of questions and which have
been used for sars cov2 vaccines also
same technology okay so what are
several things to ask so you called it
old school in a way that's uh slightly
dismissive like people talk about
windows 98 or something uh
so there
so is there risks involved with it or is
it just difficult to produce large
amounts no it takes a lot of eggs it's
very easy i mean you could do it in
cells and culture but eggs were
convenient and in the 1940s we didn't
have cells in culture we didn't know how
to do that so we had to use something
else
it's easy to do
but the process of inactivating
the virus with a chemical
makes it not a not the best vaccine you
can make the flu vaccines that we have
today which are mostly based on this
inactivation this is called inactivated
virus vaccines oh so like the kind of uh
thing it presents to the immune system
to train on is not right it's not it's
not
it's not close to the actual virus yes
that's what we think so that's why
probably the flu vaccines are just not
very good you know
60
efficiency at the best right which is
not really good what does it mean what
is the measure of efficiency for a
vaccine well
it how it does in the general population
at preventing influence at preventing
illness not infection we usually don't
measure
infection
when we're testing a vaccine we just
measure
sickness that's really easy to score
right
you
do a trial and you say if you feel sick
give us a call
you